NOW TIME FOR MY NECK, MY BACK,
MY BUSEY, AND MY CRACK.
GARY BUSEY, SEEN HERE THINKING
ABOUT A BUG IN HIS MOUTH, IS
LIKE THAT BIG OLD DOG THAT KEEPS
KNOCKING STUFF OFF YOUR COFFEE
TABLE WITH HIS TAIL BUT HE'S
JUST SO LOVABLE THAT YOU CAN'T
BRING YOURSELF TO HAVE HIM PUT
HIM DOWN.
GARY'S HAD A ROUGH TIME, AND BY
TIME, I MEAN LIFE.
DURING RECENT BANKRUPTCY
HEARINGS, WE DISCOVERED THAT
GARY ISN'T THE SHREWD INVESTOR
YOU'D THINK.
TURNS OUT HE'S RUNNING ON FUMES.
GARY'S ASSETS ARE SAID TO
INCLUDE "$50,000, OLD MOCCASINS,
A BROKEN PELLET GUN, AND MORE
THAN 300 VHS TAPES."
COMEDIANS, I WANT YOU TO TELL ME
AS MANY OF GARY BUSEY'S ASSETS
AS YOU CAN.
GO.
BAMFORD.
>> A LARGE HOAGIE.
I SAW HIM COME OUT OF THE WOODS
WHEN I WAS HIKING IN THE MALIBU
WITH AN ITALIAN SUBWAY SUB.
>> Chris: POINTS.
DAN TELFER.
>> SNAKE DICKS THAT HE FOUND ON
SOME SNAKES.
Chris: POINTS.
DAN.
>> TWO SQUIRREL SUITS. ONE FOR
SQUIRRELS, ONE MADE OUT OF
SQUIRRELS.
Chris: DAN.
>> JAKE BUSEY.
Chris: STEVE.
>> A LEGAL PAD WITH ALTERNATE
SPELLINGS OF BUSEY.
>> THIS OLD BANDAID. HE CHEWED
ON IT FOR A WHILE, BUT IT'S
STILL GOOD.
Chris: BAMFORD.
A CERAMIC DOG BANK FROM COLOR ME
MINE, HE DOESN'T PUT MONEY IN HE
JUST WHISPERS WISHES IN IT.
[LAUGHING]
>> Chris: STEVE.
>> A MASON JAR FULL OF THOUGHTS.
Chris: BAMFORD.
>> MINT CONDITION COPIES OF O
MAGAZINE.